Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number
and that number is 2192. David P,
here is a caller. Not thrilled with my
Alex Jones impression. Listen to this.
Speaker 5: Mr. Pacman. Yes, sir. If I
might offer a criticism of your show,
it's that your Alex Jones impersonation needs a
lot of work. Okay. Hey, what you want to do when
you're doing an Alex Jones impersonation? You
want to make it sound like you've just smoked
every cigaret, but you wouldn't know
anything about that. You don't even.
No. In all seriousness, I do enjoy the show.
Thank you for your interviewing acumen in
general. And I was curious if you agree that
in part the rise of Trumpism or fascism,
whatever it is you want to call it, there's some
responsibility of the people on the left who
perhaps. Are performative in their outrage when
something, you know, messed up happens because
it just kind of seems like there's a whole
wing of supporting Trump that deals with.
I just want to trigger the lid.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Listen
there. I'm not doing a both sides thing, but there
is some performative outrage on both sides. It's
over very different things, and it's tailored
and sort of focused differently. But I've seen
performative outrage on the left as well, and I
don't participate in it. And I don't even know
that I care to get into the specifics right now.
But there is performative outrage all over. Now,
as far as the Alex Jones impression, is
it that bad globalist, internationalist,
Trotskyite socialist, unlike Obama.
Speaker 3: Trudeau, Macron
and the rest of the Zio bitch?
Speaker 1: B
I don't know. I think it's okay. I generally don't
think my impressions are very good. I also do.
Susan Collins Well, I was very disappointed to see
that Donald Trump killed a man, but I think that
he's learned his lesson. And I am not in favor of
moving forward with any consequences whatsoever.
What other ones do I do? I don't know. But my
impressions are all like a four out of ten.
I think they're bad, but I think at
least it's passable who I'm referring to.
Yeah. Okay. Anyway, let's let's
move on. On today's bonus show,
there is a Florida abortion ban. This is
fascinating because it's the opposite of how
these things usually work. There are Jewish
groups now saying the Florida abortion ban
violates the religious freedom of Jewish
folks. This is this is absolutely brilliant.
There are Jewish religious teachings which say
in certain cases, you should have an abortion,
you should have an abortion. And the way that
the Florida abortion ban is written would violate
the religious freedom of those Jewish folks to
access that abortion. And we're going to talk
about that on today's bonus show. Secondly, do you
remember when Alexander Litvinenko was poisoned
by a Russian agent? This was a major story.
A few years ago, I believe it was polonium.
The agent linked to the poisoning of Litvinenko
has now died from COVID, which is a bizarre
turn of events. And then lastly, Russia has
a rebranded McDonald's. It's sort of like a
McDonald's clone because of McDonald's closing
in Russia. It's called Delicious. That's all
we will talk about, whether producer Pat can
get vegan treats at the new McDonald's clone.
And we will talk about so many other
things. Don't miss today's bonus show.
I will be on it. Pat will join me. You can
sign up at join pacman dotcom. Remember,
Alex Jones is still against you signing up.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: He still thinks it's predatory.
Speaker 3: That is a frickin predator right there.
Speaker 1: Right? I love the bonus show quite
frankly. Sign up at join pacman dot com coupon
code big voting 22 for a discount. I will
see you then or otherwise back here tomorrow.